it was back in the year 1921.
the sheikh writer carol sheppard
introduced the term
robot in a fictional play the play
focused on rossum's universal robots
which had become extremely popular for
manufacturing workers
also known as robots in very large
numbers
these manufactured workers did
everything that humans preferred
not to do but only thing was that they
lacked
emotions in check the word rabota means
forced labor or simply a worker
in a nutshell a robot can be defined as
an automatically operated machine
that replaces human effort by executing
one or
multiple jobs automatically with speed
and precision
let's have a quick look at the history
of robotic evolution
it is very easy to assume that robots
are recent inventions
but shockingly the history for robotics
stretches back
to thousand years around 400 to 350 bce
greek mathematician architects designed
and built
a steam-powered mechanical bird called
as the pigeon
the pigeon could propel itself into air
using the steam mechanism
around 1495 leonardo da vinci
another remarkable mind in the field of
engineering
designed and sketched the first humanoid
robot also known as
leonardo's robot or leonardo's
mechanical
knight this robot could set stand
and move its arms using pulleys and
cables
around 1735 jackster wilkinson
the father of simulation built at least
three highly sophisticated robotic
devices
two of them were robotic musicians which
could play
various melodies his third robotic
device was famous mechanical duck
consisting of a thousand moving parts
and gastrointestinal system
fast forward to 1927 when the first ever
humanoid robot was created and it was
named as
herbert teleworks this began the
developmental process leading to more
robots such as the electro
in the year 1939 which is widely
accepted as the first advanced humanoid
robot
to be ever created it stunned
audiences with its human-like
capabilities including
the ability to smoke a cigarette
counting the number of fingers
recognize colors and talk electro hat a
remote control instead
would respond to voice commands using a
telephone handset
connected to its chest do you know how
they pulled it off
each word had a set of vibrations and
these vibrations were converted into
electrical impulses and these electric
pulses operated the release controlling
11 motors
in the year 1972 mobot 1
the world's first full-scale android
humanoid robot was created by
waseda university japan it was the first
robot
to walk and communicate with japanese
people
navigate a room and even transport
objects
the later went to create a robot 2
capable of
reading lyric sheets and playing the
keyboard
after decades of research and
development many prototypes
honda debuted simo in the year 2000
the most advanced robot in the world
capable of running
jumping climbing stairs recognizing
moving
objects postures gestures sounds and
faces these features enabled a cmo to
interact with humans
these were possible because of the
advancements in wireless technology
programming semiconductors and sensors
the era between the year 2005 and the
year 2014 was amazing
thanks to the rise in the real robots
capable of helping
disabled persons performing dangerous
work
and accessing hazardous places
there was also the development of
industrial manipulators
and massive activity in other areas
related to manipulation in
unstructured environments and mobility
including wheeled flying underwater
legged and humanoid robots
robotics has come a long way the current
generation of robots are smarter faster
more agile and they have started to
think
all thanks to artificial intelligence
and machine learning
which is giving a new evolution to
robots
artificial intelligence technology helps
robots understand human behavior
and these intelligent robots will become
a significant part of our lives
soon in the year 2016
the world's first artificially
intelligent robot citizen
sophia was created and programmed by
hanson robotics
a hong kong-based humanoid robotics
company
it is just the first part to ignite in
the era of artificially intelligent
robots
sophia has the sense of humor express
feelings
and interacts with people sophia is the
first robot in the world to be
recognized
with citizenship in saudi arabia
sofia will be the pioneer and will help
to increase
public awareness of artificially
intelligent ethics
and the future of robotics the
applications of
robots are extensive and have found uses
in surgery
massage therapy space exploration
manufacturing and code analysis today
there are multifunctional
coordinated nanobots that can carry out
medical marvels such as
nil invasive surgeries before the
pandemic and the economic uncertainty
that followed
statistic market research consulting
expected that
global humanoid robot market would reach
13 billion by 2026 while
future market behavior is now unclear
robot usage is
on the rise and many countries are
deploying robots and automation
technology
as doctors are grappling with current
situation
we have come to a long way to the age of
artificially infused autonomous machines
where robots are granted citizenship and
digital humans are a thing while
recalling that
robots were initially supposed to be
doing only labor-intensive
mindless jobs artificially intelligent
technology is
slowly advancing robotics to a
singularity stage
it is no longer possible to
differentiate between humans and robots
as robots are now capable to perform
jobs more precisely
faster and seamlessly